and the Emmy goes to the boy the voice  took home the Emmy on Sunday night for  Best reality competition but when it  came time for the in memoriam segment  one of its stars was missing Christina  Grimmie the 22 year old who competed on  it season 6 of the NBC show she was of  course tragically killed in June after  one of her concerts fans were upset that  christina was omitted from the segment  which featured other singers including  Merle Haggard Natalie Cole Prince and  David Bowie a spokesperson for the Emmys  explained why Grammy wasn't included in  a statement to ET Monday quote every  year the telecast producer is  unfortunately limited by the time  available and cannot include every  significant person who has passed in the  telecast Grammy was included on the  Emmys website and in the backstage live  streaming programs on screen crawled  during the segment a representative for  the late singer declined to comment  you